j'aimerais devenir un bon écrivain ni
les amis ni les petites amies ne
m'intéressait je ne faisait qu écrire
que lire et que marmonner dans ma barbe
maintenant à new york
on n'est jamais à plus de 10 mètres de
quelqu'un qu'on connaît ou qu'on devrait
connaître et vous vous appelez aryenne
marié nous avons choisi 7,70 être avec
toi reviendrait à voir une liste si tu
change d'opinion tu me trouveras
toujours au coin des fumeurs le vendredi
ce mot 2006
papa je voulais te présenter arié le
pire on a chanté par les web
eh bien j'ai 33 ans je suis mariée et
mère des enfants
il ya deux forces sur cette terre qu'il
ne sert à rien de combattre l'une
d'elles c'est la nature et l'autre c'est
l'amour suit les boues d'ariel ça me
fait très plaisir que vous veniez dîner
chez nous le samedi qui vient en famille
lien entre et quand on ne voit
si vous voulez devenir un écrivain digne
de ce nom vous vous pouvez pas vivre
dans la médiocrité
la seule chose que je veux vraiment sur
cette terre c'est être l'homme qui
marche à tes côtés
il ya des personnes qui ont épousé des
personnes car même